♪♪
>>> WITH RUSSIA PLANNING TO MOVE
TROOPS INTO REBEL-HELD REGIONS
OF EASTERN UKRAINE AND PERHAPS
REBEL-HELD CLAIMEDREAS OF
EASTERN UKRAINE THAT THEY DON'T
CONTROL, HOW WOULD A FULL-SCALE
WAR IN UKRAINE REFLECT ON
BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY?
JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS ARE
CNN SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST AND
THE AUTHOR OF "LINCOLN AND THE
FIGHT FOR PEACE" JOHN AVLON AND
THE AUTHOR OF "THE MAN WHO RAN
WASHINGTON, THE LIFE AND TIMES
OF JAMES A. BAKER, III" SUSAN
GLASSER WITH YOU.
TO YOU FIRST, SUSAN.
WHAT IS AT STAKE FOR BIDEN?
>> THIS IS UNDOUBTEDLY THE
BIGGEST INTERNATIONAL CRISIS OF
BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY.
AND REALLY ANY IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS.
IT'S AN OUTRIGHT CHALLENGE BY
RUSSIA AS WE HEARD YESTERDAY
FROM VLADIMIR PUTIN IN THAT
EXTRAORDINARY SPEECH BASICALLY
DEFYING INTERNATIONAL LAW,
BLACKMAILING A NEIGHBOR,
BLACKMAILING ALL OF EUROPE WITH
THE NOTION THAT AN INDEPENDENT
COUNTRY ON HIS BORDERS IS NOT A
REAL COUNTRY BECAUSE HE THINKS
IT SHOULD STILL BE PART OF A
RUSSIAN EMPIRE.
>> JOHN, YOU SAY THIS ISN'T JUST
IMPORTANT WHEN IT COMES TO
BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT FOR THE
TRAJECTORY OF THE 21st CENTURY.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT?
>> BIDEN HAS BEEN VERY CLEAR ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES OF OUR TIMES
IS THIS ISSUE OF DEMOCRACY
VERSUS AUTOCRACY.
WHICH WAY WILL THE WORLD TREND
IN THE 21st CENTURY?
AND IF PUTIN IS ABLE TO MENACE A
DEMOCRATIC NEIGHBOR, ERASE
THROUGH TROOP MOVEMENTS,
FICTION, THAT'S AN EXISTENTIAL
FOR THE INTERNATIONAL ORDER.
THAT'S WHY THIS IS SO CRITICAL
FOR THE BIDEN PRESIDENCY AND A
REAL TEST WHETHER DEMOCRACIES
AND MULTILATERAL ORGANIZATIONS
CAN HANG TOGETHER AS A
COUNTERWEIGHT TO THESE
AUTOCRATIC AND AUTHORITARIAN
BULLIES.
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT UKRAINE,
TAIWAN IN THE FUTURE.
BUT WE'RE DEALING WITH THE HERE
AND NOW AND THAT'S WHY THERE
MUST BE A ROBUST RESPONSE BY
DEMOCRATIC NATIONS TO CONSTRAIN
THIS AGGRESSION.
>> SUSAN, DEPENDING ON HOW BIG
THIS GETS, YOU'RE LOOKING AT
ECONOMIC RAMIFICATIONS THAT ARE
GOING TO TRICKLE DOWN TO
AMERICANS ALREADY STRUGGLING
WITH INFLATION, IT WOULD BE
HIGHER.
CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT AND ALSO JUST THE
REPUTATION OF JOE BIDEN COMING
OFF OF A BAD WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN AND WHAT A BAD
SITUATION IN UKRAINE COULD ALSO
MEAN FOR HIM?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
THIS IS ENORMOUSLY HIGH-STAKES
DECISIONS THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
MAKING NOW AND IN THE COMING
DAYS.
AND THIS CRISIS, BY THE WAY, IS
LIKELY TO GO ON FOR QUITE SOME
TIME.
FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN, FIRST OF
ALL, THE STAKES ARE WHAT DOES IT
DO TO HIS FORTUNES INSIDE THE
U.S.
I DO THINK THE ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES OF WHAT AMERICANS
LARGELY VIEW AS A FAR AWAY
CONFLICT THAT DOES NOT INVOLVE
THEM, I DON'T KNOW HOW PREPARED
THEY ARE REALLY FOR THE IDEA
THAT ENERGY PRICES MAY FURTHER
GO UP, FOR THE IDEA THAT SOME
SACRIFICES REQUIRE FOREIGN
POLICY HAS NOT BEEN AT THE TOP
OF THE POLITICAL AGENDA.
AMERICANS HAVE UNDERSTANDABLY
BEEN INWARD LOOKING, FOCUSSED ON
THE PANDEMIC AND ALL OF THE
ASSORTED ENORMOUS FALLOUT INSIDE
OUR SOCIETY, THE UNRAVELING OF
OUR OWN DEMOCRACY IN MANY WAYS.
SO THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, WHAT ABOUT THE
EXTREME PARTISANSHIP WITH WHICH
EVERYTHING, INCLUDING FOREIGN
POLICY, HAS BECOME SORT OF
TRANSFORMED IN RECENT YEARS IN
WASHINGTON?
ARE REPUBLICANS TRADITIONALLY
WILLING TO BE TOUGH ON RUSSIA
BUT NOW HAVE A LEADER AND
ENORMOUS FACTION IN TRUMP AND
HIS SUPPORTERS WHO HAVE
ESSENTIALLY BEEN PRO-PUTIN IN
RECENT YEARS.
AND SO HOW IS THAT GOING TO
AFFECT BIDEN'S ABILITY TO SPEAK
AS THE LEADER OF A UNITED
COUNTRY THAT IS DIVIDED
INTERNALLY.
SO I THINK IT'S NOT AT ALL
CLEAR, YOU KNOW, WHAT THE UPSIDE
POLITICALLY IS FOR BIDEN BUT
THERE'S ENORMOUS RISK FOR HIM
BOTH DOMESTICALLY POLITICALLY
AND INTERNATIONALLY, KEEPING
EUROPEANS ON THE SAME PAGE IS
VERY DIFFICULT.
BIG NEWS THIS MORNING WHICH IS
GERMANY CANCELING THE NORD
STREAM 2 PIPELINE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT BIDEN
WANTED.
THAT OBAMA AND TRUMP WANTED.
NEVER HAPPENED UNTIL NOW.
SO THAT'S A BIG, BIG STEP
FORWARD IN TERMS OF ALLIED UNITY
AGAINST RUSSIA.
>> YEAH.
NO, IT'S A VERY BIG STEP.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, JOHN?
I SAW YOU REACTING THERE.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, NORD
STREAM 2 IS A HUGE PRESSURE
POINT.
IT DOES GET TO THE FACT THAT WE
NEED TO WEAN OURSELVES OFF THESE
SORT OF KLEPTOCRACIES THAT HAVE
FOSSIL FUEL INFLUENCE ON OTHER
ECONOMIES.
IT'S YET ANOTHER REASON TO MOVE
IN THAT DIRECTION.
LOOK, I DON'T THINK AT THE END
OF THE DAY WILL THERE BE
ADDITIONAL ECONOMIC PRESSURE ON
AMERICANS AND PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD IF WE STAND UP TO
AGGRESSION, YES?
BUT WHAT THE SACRIFICE BEING
REQUESTED FROM PEOPLE TO DEFEND
DEMOCRACY LIBERAL INTERNATIONAL
ORDER THAT BROUGHT IN 75 YEARS
OF PEACE AND PROSPERITY IN
EUROPE, SOMETHING UNPRECEDENTED
IN THE WAKE OF WORLD WAR II,
THAT AMERICA AND ITS ALLIES
HELPED BUILD, WE NEED TO
REMEMBER THAT WE'RE NOT FRAGILE
THINGS, MADE OF SUGAR CANDY.
DEALING WITH A LITTLE BIT OF
DIFFICULTY TO STAND DOWN
AUTHORITARIANISM AND AUTOCRACY
IS NOT TOO MUCH TO ASK.
WE NEED TO STRAIGHTEN AND
STIFFEN OUR SPINES.
>> CAN I CHALLENGE YOU ON THAT A
LITTLE BIT, JOHN?
I JUST THINK THAT MAY BE THE
CASE FOR SOME PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, BUT FOR OTHER PEOPLE
WHEN THEY'RE MAKING TOUGH
DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER THEY CAN
TAKE A CERTAIN JOB BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T PUT THAT GAS IN THEIR CAR
OR THE PRICE OF GROCERIES HAVE
GONE UP AND INSTEAD OF BEING
ABLE TO FEED THEIR KIDS GROUND
BEEF, THEY HAVE TO FEED THEM
BEANS OR SOMETHING ELSE, YOU
KNOW, THAT IS SORT OF A
DEPARTURE FOR THEM FROM WHAT
THEY WOULD PREFER TO, YOU
KNOW --
>> SURE.
>> -- THAT'S A LOT TO ASK.
HOW ARE YOU EXPECTING PEOPLE TO
FOCUS ON DEMOCRACY WHEN THE
KITCHEN TABLE ISSUES ARE EATING
THEM UP?
>> WELL, I THINK TWO THINGS
ABOUT THAT, BRI.
YOU'RE RIGHT, OBVIOUSLY.
PEOPLE ARE FEELING A LOT OF
DIFFICULTY, BUT THAT'S ALSO
WHERE GOVERNMENT CAN TAKE ACTION
TO ALLEVIATE SOME SHORT-TERM
STRESS.
SECOND OF ALL, WE RUN A REAL
RISK OF TAKING DEMOCRACY'S GAINS
OF LIVING MEMORY FOR GRANTED.
IF PEOPLE WANT TO LIVE IN A 21st
CENTURY THAT'S DOMINATED BY
AUTOCRATS AND AUTOCRACIES, I
THINK THEY WOULD VERY QUICKLY
REALIZE THAT THAT IS A DANGEROUS
TRADE THAT UNDERMINES ALL THE
LIBERTIES THAT THEY HAVE TAKEN
FOR GRANTED IN THE PAST.
SO, GOVERNMENT HAS
RESPONSIBILITY TO ALLEVIATE SOME
OF THAT PAIN.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
GOVERNMENT EXISTS.
SUSAN POINTS OUT THE PARTISAN
DIVIDE IN WASHINGTON IS
TROUBLING.
THERE ARE, HOWEVER A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE LESS LOUD
THAN THE ISOLATIONIST WING.
BUT DON'T UNDERESTIMATE THE
TRAJECTORY IMPLICATIONS OF THIS
PARTICULAR MOMENT.
AND I KNOW FOLKS ARE TIRED.
I KNOW THEY'RE FRUSTRATED.
BUT WHAT WE'RE BEING ASKED TO DO
AND WHAT WE HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
DO IS FAR LESS THAN OTHER
GENERATIONS HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
DO.
WE SHOULD KEEP THAT IN MIND AS
WELL.
THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD TAKE TOOX
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE PRESSURES
AND PAINS THAT PEOPLE ARE
FEELING.
IT'S REAL.
>> SUSAN, WHAT -- OBVIOUSLY JOE
BIDEN CAN'T CONTROL WHAT IS OUT
OF HIS CONTROL.
WHAT IS WITHIN HIS CONTROL RIGHT
NOW?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I THINK
IT'S ENORMOUSLY ON AMERICAN
PRESIDENTIAL LEADERSHIP.
THIS IS A MOMENT HE SAID WHEN HE
CAME INTO THE PRESIDENCY AMERICA
IS BACK.
THAT WAS HIS MESSAGE TO EUROPEAN
ALLIES AND PARTNERS.
AND INTERESTINGLY I THINK AFTER
THE STRUGGLES OF THE FIRST YEAR
AND, YOU KNOW, BOTH WITH
AFGHANISTAN THERE WERE SOME
FEELING AMONG SOME EUROPEANS
THAT THEY HAD NOT BEEN FULLY
CONSULTED DESPITE HAVING BEEN
WITH THE U.S. FOR 20 YEARS.
THERE WAS THE RIFT WITH THE
FRENCH OVER THE NEW DEAL WITH
THE AUSTRALIANS.
AND SO IN A WAY THOSE TESTS IT'S
PROBABLY GOOD THEY CAME BEFORE
THIS BIG ALL-CONSUMING CHALLENGE
FOR BIDEN.
I THINK THERE'S A SENSE COMING
OUT OF THE BIG MUNICH STRATEGY
CONFERENCE, SECURITY CONFERENCE
LAST WEEK, THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
U.S. ACTUALLY IS BACK AT ITS
SEAT AT THE HEAD OF THE TABLE.
THERE'S BEEN ENORMOUS EFFORT
PLACED INTO DIPLOMACY AND ON TO
BEING ON THE SAME PAGE WITH
ALLIES, PREPARING THESE
SANCTIONS IN ADVANCE, SHARING
INTELLIGENCE TO AN UNPRECEDENTED
DEGREE.
SO THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
DOUBLED DOWN ON THE IDEA THAT
AMERICA IS STILL CAPABLE AND
WILLING AND ABLE TO LEAD IN A
21st CENTURY KIND OF CHALLENGE
LIKE THIS.
THE TEST IS GOING TO BE, A, CAN
HE KEEP IT TOGETHER?
PUTIN IS A VERY EXPERIENCED
ADVERSARY AND IT SEEMS THAT HE'S
CALIBRATING MANY OF HIS MOVES TO
MAXIMIZE THE POTENTIAL FOR
DISAGREEMENT AMONG THE ALLIES.
SO I THINK THAT'S GOING